I am a labor organizer and in 2013 I
co-founded an organization called
co-worker org that uses technology to
help people join with co-workers and
organize for improvements in the
workplace now there are two kinds of
reactions to what I do actually know
there are three the first is complete
confusion about what organizing is when
my doctor asked what I do and I told him
he thought I meant organizing like Marie
Kondo style he was like oh that's so
great I could use some of that around
here I would love to clean up our
patient files and I had explained to him
that no no no it's it's not that kind of
organizing it's more like if you showed
up to work tomorrow and all the nurses
in the office had gotten together to ask
for an across-the-board raise oh he
replied and he got really quiet yeah and
that's the second kind of reaction the
uncomfortable kind people usually
withdraw from the conversation and find
someone else to talk to well finally
there's the third reaction the excited
one the oh my god yes we need this and
someone always proceeds to tell me a
story it's always a story about a job or
a co-worker or a friend who's enduring
something awful at work what I've
noticed is that there is never a neutral
response to what I do
you're either repelled by it or you're
struck with a lightning bolt of
excitement so why does my work stir up
such strong reactions my hunch is that
it's about conflict if you have power in
your workplace maybe as a CEO or a
senior leader of some kind you're gonna
feel uncomfortable with that power being
challenged but if you lack power or you
know someone who lacks it and needs it
you might grab me by the shoulders and
shake me you're so pumped but really we
can all benefit from understanding what
conflict can offer
in our workplaces the power imbalance in
our workplace is real and it's
constantly changing power moves between
us depending on our roles and status now
sometimes this can feel like office
politics right which is never fun but
when we can test for power thoughtfully
and together with our co-workers it can
be incredibly productive and it's that
kind of productive conflict that I want
to talk to you all about today the kind
that can make some of us uncomfortable
business leaders should embrace when
their workers conflict with policies and
decisions both for what it teaches us
and for what it says about our
commitment to each other so what do I
mean by productive conflict well let me
tell you a story in 2016 a store
employee for an outdoor retailer I'll
call her Alex Alex approached her boss
and asked for a raise now she was told
her pay was fairly standard for her
position and that her boss didn't even
have the authority to give such a raise
and that was supposed to be the end of
the conversation unhappy with that
answer Alex went home and she decided to
create a campaign on co-worker org
asking the corporate office to give
raises to store employees within days
employees from around the country began
joining Alex's effort and sharing their
own stories about what they were earning
eleven twelve dollars an hour and how
that wage was impacting their lives some
even shared that they had quit recently
to work for competitors who paid more
but here's the thing they also shared
that they didn't want to quit they liked
their job they believed in the company's
mission but for them the pay issue was a
growing problem in their work lives
well after weeks of this groundswell of
employee activism the company decided to
raise wages by five to fifteen percent
in cities across the country
and that's what I mean by productive
conflict pushing up against the things
that aren't working for us when there
exists no other path forward the other
thing I learned in doing this work is
that people engage in productive
conflict when they care about their jobs
and their co-workers now that surprised
me at first I I expected the worst jobs
the worst work
is to have the most employee activism on
our site but the opposite is often true
when we come together we we can
accomplish great things and at one
company there are more than 50 campaigns
by employees there on issues ranging
from dress code changes to legitimate
safety concerns and get this that same
company has the lowest voluntary
turnover rate of any major chain in its
sector and it also has one of the higher
productivity rates as well business
leaders you shouldn't fear conflict and
you shouldn't try to tamp down on it the
minute it bubbles up in your workforce
while it can introduce uncertainties
that can be difficult to manage those
uncertainties are trying to tell you
something about an underlying problem
that needs your attention and I think
this is especially important right now
you know as as technology transforms
nearly everyone's job and as are the
structures that contain our work are
changing in a pace not seen since the
Industrial Revolution we all need to be
shaping and participating in the future
of work we all need to be challenging
and changing the parts of our work lives
that are broken so I hope you know the
next time a co-worker invites you maybe
to join a sign on letter to your boss or
a group of employees asks for a meeting
to discuss their concerns about the new
health care plan I hope you'll consider
it an opportunity to build a better
workplace a stronger business and an
economy that works for all of us
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]